let's do some talk boubles TK let's do
it since we're talking about emotional
baggage today emotional clutter
emotional
damage come on maning fruit here is a
great tip to avoid emotionally charged
impulse purchases take a look at this
video do you find yourself buying decor
and then when you get it home you really
don't like it as much as you thought you
did when I go shopping all these colors
and pretty displays overwhelm me but
before I buy anything I take it to the
trash meaning the trash can aisle in the
store so this vase it looked gorgeous
surrounded by all this beautiful foliage
but in the trash can aisle it kind of
looked like a weird dut and then this
vase I loved it surrounded by the reads
but in the trash can aisle I realized I
could probably find the same thing at
goodwi for cheaper if I like it in the
trash can aisle then I will buy it cuz I
know it'll be pretty anywhere that's so
smart what I thought this was going
initially was like take it to the trash
can aisle and then throw it out that
that was like that seems like a JF f m
tip before you buy it throw it away and
I can imagine like just me at Target and
I'm just taking a bunch of things of a
trash can out just literally put it in
trash cans and then walking out of the
store sir we're going to have to ask you
to
leave wouldn't be the first time I was
kicked out of a retail store but I
really enjoy this because it's not about
the trash cans per se it's about taking
the object out of its natural
environment putting some space between
the impulse of the moment and the actual
purchase itself we have something called
the wait for it rule also known as a
3030 rule if something costs more than
$30 why not wait 30 hours to buy it
because you're putting some space
between the I've got to have it right
now instant
gratification and you know what if I
wait a day and I still feel like I'm
really going to get value from this it's
going to enhance my life I don't want to
deprive myself of it but I've made some
space between the impulse and the
purchase itself
yeah I think I want to apply this to
people like hey man come over here and
stand next to this trash can with me
right quick and like oh okay I guess
you're all
right I guess you can stick
around hey but seriously though man it's
kind of like trying on clothes right uh
where it looks great on that mannequin
but man there there are some people
they're so beautiful anything looks good
on them but then when you try it on
yourself you're like oh okay it looked
amazing on him but it just doesn't fit
me but I love how she just basically
creatively applied that to things that's
a brilliant idea yeah instead of just
seeing it on the mannequin and buying it
actually trying it on because your house
doesn't look like the aisle in which
you're purchasing this from yeah and so
in a way you're trying on that item just
by putting it in a different context a
different setting and if you're still
like oh yeah and by the way this would
look really great on my dresser on my
credenza or look great in my kitchen
wherever wonderful if you really want it
and you think it will enhance your life
but that's staving off the impulse to
see whether or not it's actually going
to add value don't do this with food
though cuz nothing probably looks good
next to a trash
can that's TK's tip of the
week a few months ago we had uh Dr sha
Oma on the podcast remember we watched
the video with him where people were
eating ice cream out chocolate ice cream
out of a toilet bowl and it was the
perfect thing cuz I like oh I can
chocolate ice cream is delicious but if
you have it in a toilet imagine you had
it in your actual toilet at home I don't
care how delicious that stuff is it
would be a big hurdle try to try to eat
that ice
cream I hope you enjoyed that highlight
from the minimalist private podcast if
you like another highlight check out
this video if you'd like to watch the
minimal episode check out this video or
if you'd like to dive deep into full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast head on over to patreon the link
is in the description your support keeps
our podcast and YouTube channel 100%
advertisement free